una frase concreta de este discurso que
fue el que repitió varias veces y es que
la democracia está en el tarjetón
electoral el próximo 8 de noviembre le
pidió también a los votantes paciencia
cada estado tiene leyes electorales
diferentes y el conteo de los votos la
noche del 8 de noviembre se va a demorar
y Por ende le pidió entonces a los
republicanos simpatizantes de Donald
Trump que por favor tengan paciencia que
esto no es cuestión de fraude resaltó
que no va a permitir que la democracia
en Estados Unidos sea violentada como
ocurrió precisamente con Nancy pelosi
Hace unos días donde una persona se
metió a su casa buscandola diciendo
dónde esta Nancy Dónde están Nancy
palabras similares que repitieron los
que se tomaron el Capitolio en el 6 de
enero del 2021 resaltó que hay 300
candidatos en estas elecciones de medio
término que no han querido reconocer los
resultados electorales del 2020 Y
entonces le pide
al pueblo estadounidense que salga a
votar que defienda la democracia que no
lo tome por hecho resaltó también que
pues hay cifras de votación anticipada
27 millones de estadounidenses ya han
votado se espera que sean muchos más Los
que acudan además a las urnas el 8 de
noviembre y dijo específicamente que no
va a tolerar la violencia ni la
intimidación al votante que ya se ha
venido presentando en algunos estados
precisamente ya de forma preventiva
reconocida no reconociendo los
resultados que es la amenaza que esta
noche el presidente ha querido Resaltar
frente a la democracia que repitió está
en el tarjetón y Por ende invita a votar
al estadounidense